hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our match
between paul charles murphy and james
stanley kipping and if you're wondering
why
keeping aged some 30 years since the
previous video now he actually didn't i
just used a wrong photo as they come
from a
pretty big family of whom a lot of them
played
chess i accidentally used a different
photo
so this is actually uh chess master
james stanley keeping not
the younger gentleman i've shown you in
the previous video so that being said
let's check out the game
and also if you are just joining in uh
know that you can always check out
the entire morphe saga from the
beginning the link will be the first
thing you see in the description below
and if by any chance this is too much
for you you can also check out the first
game between these two gentlemen as
it's also quite a beauty so getting back
to the game
i will also just mention that uh morphe
decided to go to birmingham tournament
which opened on august 24th uh only
after the tournament started and that is
on august 26th so this is also a smart
fi
a small small part uh from lawson's book
like we mentioned
morphe did not want to arrive before the
tournament started because it would be
too hard for him
not to actually join the tournament it
would be like you know i'm there
i must play chess so uh this decision
remained quite incomprehensible as he
could have played against staunton uh
participating in the tournament but
morphy
like we already said did not want to
face staunton in the tournament he
wanted to face him in a match
let's say over a course of 10 games and
then to see who is
actually better because just winning one
game in a tournament uh would not
uh really state that he's the better
player and he did not travel to england
just so he could
maybe be a better player so morphy
wanted to challenge staunton alone as he
had challenged lowenthal
and win it morphy saw staunton in
birmingham and once again invited him to
a direct meeting and staunton replied
that he would have time sometimes
in november to compensate for the
disappointment of the participants
morphy offered the committee to play a
blindfold simultaneous with eight
players
on august 27th so uh thomas avery
persuaded the american
to play two games in the meantime with
the secretary of the chess club mr james
stanley keeping this is mr james stanley
keeping the secretary of the chess club
also chess master
uh so they did uh this is game two now
let's check it out so
uh keeping opens with e4 sorry about
that
uh morphe replies with e5 uh we have
knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 and yes i
know you
you're wondering is it going to be it
again
uh morphy replies with bishop to c5 and
in the previous game they played of
course morphe went for the
for the evans gambit in this position
and uh james stanley keeping shows that
he's a true gentleman and
replies with b4 he also goes for the
evan's gamut and now we're gonna see
uh you know some a lot of fun on the
chess board so here uh morphe of course
accepts the gambit we have c3
and now morphe plays bishop to c5 now if
you remember i made a
a tutorial on the evan's game but i said
here you go bishop a5 d6 or e7 you do
not go bishop to c5
but this is exactly what morphe plays
and it's uh
it's uh there's a reason why i said you
shouldn't play it
uh but in those days uh you could have
played it but even today in 2020 it's
still being played but you really have
to
know why you're doing it so here we have
d4
uh e captures on d4 and now c captures
on d4 immediately recapturing towards
the center
although a bit more ambitious play would
be something like maybe castles or
or developing the queen but okay c
captures on d4
challenging the bishop and now another
bishop to b for check
morphe goes back bishop to b6 and here
again you could go for something like
castles but keeping immediately goes for
d5 and attacks morphy's knight some
morphe has to go to a5
knight to a5 attacks the bishop and
bishop to d3
and by going for this d5 maneuver
maneuver uh
he stranded morphy's knight here on a5
and the knight really doesn't have a
way of getting back so at some point
he's going to have to move the bishop
play b6 maybe remaneuver the knight via
the b7 square
it's not going to be easy so here d6 and
the bishop to b2 white's bishop pair is
uh
very nice here it's not fully
operational yet but
you know if this e pawn for for example
uh disappears or
gets sacrificed or gets traded off it's
just gonna be a beautiful bishop pair
so knight f6 morphe is ready to castle
and h3 now not allowing this bishop to
develop all the way to g4
we have castles by morphe that's not
castles
uh castles by morphe and castles by
kipping and now
knights to h5 morphe now says okay
you've developed your bishop to this
diagonal uh
the f4 square is available the g3 square
is also available as the f pawn is
pinned you can you will not be able to
capture with uh
with the pawn since uh the bishop
controls this diagonal
and uh it just makes sense to play
knight to h5
also he makes room for the f5 pawn so
queen d2
takes care of the f4 square but now just
f5 as planned with
knights the a3 uh getting the knight
into the game
and now comes knight to g3 by morphe
putting pressure on the roof like i said
the knight cannot be captured rook after
e1
and now f captures on e4 with this
maneuver morphe destroyed white's
white's great center and he will later
undermine it with c6
so bishop captures an e4 and now bishop
to f5
uh developing while also offering to
trade off a pair of bishops with bishop
captures
and here morphy captured with the knight
although capturing with the rook
would have been more precise as the
knight still controls the very important
e4 square and this is exactly white's
next move
so here morphe captured back with the
knight but now rook to e4
and what do you play now we have queen
to d7 by morphe
and now comes bishop to c3 and it seems
like morphe blundered a piece because
the knight is under attack and you don't
have
any squares you can move it to and
there's no way to add another defender
to the knight
but morphy planned all of this out he
just plays bishop to c5
and now the knight is under attack as
well so if you capture on a5 morphe
captures on a3 so knight back to c2
and now comes b6 and the knight is
nicely defended and even though
it seems like you can win a pawn here on
the queen side and sometimes you should
win a pawn this is not one of those
cases if you go for the pawn here
captures captures and captures
then black can just uh get a completely
dominating position knight g3
now with an attack on the rook and if
you move the rook rook let's say back to
e1
now you can go rook characters on f3 and
white's position just falls apart for
example captures capture screen captures
on h3
and there is no defense against
checkmate here
so here after b6 uh of course uh keeping
uh
ignores the knight he's not some noise
keeping his also a chess master
uh we have uh queen to g5 now bringing
the queen into the attack now there's a
lot of pressure on the g7 pawn and
morphy needs to be careful
so rook 8 a8 of course you have to bring
that last brook into the game and
kipping does the same he doubles up on
the e file
and morphe trades once with captures
captures and now
h6 uh getting rid of kipping's queen
queen back to g4 now uh there could be
some problems here if
there this knight is attacked uh one
time uh too many
uh the knight cannot move the queen on
d7 would hang so here morphy plays rook
to f7
and the queen is now nicely defended we
have rook to e6 by keeping
and here morphy just goes after the
defender of the rook c6 like we said
uh later the d5 pawn will be undermined
with the c6 move
and here uh i'm not going to tell you
what keeping played just yet
uh because there's a there is a very
sneaky line and there's a there's a
beautiful move
white can play here not to win the game
or anything but it's just the strongest
move in the position
so i think it'd be it'd be really good
for you if you tried
to spot this move so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for white
well i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations as it's
it's an extremely difficult move to find
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
bishop to f6 and this is just a wow move
because uh
you now block the rook's defense of the
knight and the queen captures knight is
just the threat
so black cannot just capture here
because you would capture the knight
and uh immediately defend the rook so
what we would see here
as the knight needs to move you will
move the knight and now we would see a
capture fest here
captures uh on e7 captures on e7
captures and captures and now
queen the c8 check this is the point now
if the king moves
you can capture on c6 and you get a
beautiful pass pawn
so black would have to defend with queen
queen to f8 and now you just play queen
to e6 with
check and now black could be you know a
little bit adventurous
to try and go for something like king to
h8 not king to h7 king to h7 would be a
terrible blunder
we can even show it and now you can just
capture and if knight captures queen to
e4 check picks up the knight so that
that'd be terrible
so instead what we would see here is
either king to h8 which doesn't
which doesn't look all that impressive
or queen to f7 and now we would most
likely see a perpetual check here
queen blocks check your queen blocks
check your queen blocks and we will get
a
draw by threefold repetition uh i don't
think a draw by threefold repetition
existed in those days but they would
just say okay this is a draw
so uh that's what's in the position
bishop f6 is definitely the strongest
move it's hard to say if keeping saw it
or not
uh but since he did lose the first game
he probably even if he saw it he
he probably would not play it as he he
would not be happy with
with a loss and a draw against morphy so
instead he goes knight c
to d4 uh gets another knight into the
game and now morphy just captures on the
e5 c captures on the e5 and now queen to
g6 and now
again we have a very very tricky
position
because you could go after the knight
here for example knight captures and e4
bishop captures sorry bishop captures
bishop captures and now knight captures
on d4 and
uh we it would be a really funky
position
uh where black would be up two pawns but
the white would have a very firm grip on
the position and black's doubled pawns
uh it's hard to say
how morphy would would break through
here it's not uh
definitely not an easy position to play
and you you have to be careful if you
play something like not that
but if you let's say try rook f4 you go
after the knight then just knight f5 and
it's pretty much game over not much you
can do here this is a threat
the rook cannot get back into the game
it is just a terrible position knight
capture series a threat tonight here
check is a threat so everything is just
winning for white so instead after this
queen to g6 move
we have the immediate knights the e7 now
attacking the queen and here uh queen
back to g3 by keeping
and now okay there is some pressure on
d6 so morphe
should be a bit careful but now uh
there's a
move that just wins the game for morphe
i mean it it allows him to
gain a winning advantage so it's again
not an easy move to find
feel free to pause the video here and
spot the idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those who were able to do it
uh congratulations as
the hardest move to find is usually with
the knight back
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to c6
and now there's a problem there's now uh
uh
well the the knight is overloaded
because if you trade once on d4 then the
rook on e6 will not be defended again
so if you try just moving the rook rook
to e1 then
just uh a whole lot of things are
winning for white for example knight
captures and the e4
knight captures and knight f5 now will
make the position pretty much unplayable
for white for example knight captures
queen captures
there's now a triple attack here on the
f2 pawn and after you defended rookie
two
now you just start pushing your d-pawn
and this is enough to
win the game for example bishop goes
here d3 attacks the rook rue goes back
and now queen e4 threatens check to pick
up the rook
still uh the f2 pawn uh being uh under
siege so
white would just completely crack under
under pressure here
so instead after knight eight to c6 uh
keeping decided not to move the rook but
instead he decided to capture here
saying okay if you capture my rook which
he did he has
knight to d8 check now attacking
morphy's queen and the rook
but here morphy just played queen to g6
and it was uh in this position that
james stanley keeping resigned the game
and another
great victory against the evans gambit
for paul charles murphy
on his trip to birmingham so here you
resign
uh you could play it out still but
keeping uh as he saw that there's no way
for him to win the game or
me you know very slim chances for him to
even draw the game it would be it would
take a really
really bad play on morphy's part for
this game to end up in a draw now
because after you trade queens because
there is a threat of queen captures on
g3 the f-pawn is still pinned you will
not be able to capture
so let's say captures captures and you
grab the rook on f7 king captures you're
still up two pawns
and it's just too easy of a position for
black to play you're just gonna bring
the king into the game push the pawn and
uh i mean win the game so i'm
keeping saw all of this and he said okay
it's uh time to time to call it a day
and uh yeah of course another great
victory for paul morphy
so these are the only two games he
played against uh
one player uh on his trip to birmingham
i will go through
uh the simultaneous games uh morphe
played on the
next day if they are recorded i will try
to find them if there are some nice ones
we'll also
show that and then uh we will see what
happens next
in the morphe saga uh so yeah uh that's
uh the game i do hope you guys enjoyed
it
it's really incredible that uh the only
two games morphy played in birmingham
against chess master james stanley
kipping
uh were games where the evans gambit was
on the board so that's you know that's
something to share with your friends
at the bar in the library definitely uh
but yeah
once again i do hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank mr hoody guy
benjamin uh spagna richard fitton uh
another hoodie guy
and uh uh uh uh sorry
aniruda ramakrishna sonde for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day